all right so we'll touch base again on
this
what what I refer to as the spiral
rotating Cross of
aikido's
um tactical responses okay so we don't
want to ever contest okay we want to
non-contest and this is basic to
jiujitsu AO being a
jiujitsu you're going to non contest
okay obviously it's basic to almost
every single East Asian art because of
the Silk Road culture thread that runs
through all of them okay um non-
contestation is universal also to any
viable fighting system because it
doesn't require you to be stronger than
your
enemy so there are um what we have come
now to see as fighting systems but if
you pay attention they're usually sport
or sport derived in which case the size
of your opponent is artificially
controlled for and you don't need to
know how to
non-contest um in order to gain Victory
it's actually probably not as economical
as just a short blast of overpowering
somebody that you're capable of doing so
upon is going to be much more economical
and that's where you see Sports uh
that's where you're also seeing a
degradation of um martial arts that were
classically geared towards non-c
contestation but having enter a sport
environment weight categories then
thrust upon them and now you start
seeing more contestation within those
that's what's happening to Modern BJJ uh
for example which and which is why
current practitioners don't have the
skill of practitioners 20 30 years ago
that could easily grapple uh way above
their weight class okay that that's a
disappearing skill uh recently on the
Facebook page I I shared with you guys
that um that video of that much smaller
guy probably that opponent had 100
pounds on him and you could see the
strength difference because every once
in a while where the smaller guy
contested he just got thrown around like
a rag doll but all the other places um
where he would not contest uh he was
able to maintain position and then
eventually he beats that guy okay that's
just classic fighting systems of a
practical kind uh along the same vein
for the officers out there that follow
me this is why I can't stand modern law
enforcement um defensive tactics or
arrest and control because it's always
based upon the
asymmetrical
um combative engagement as opposed to an
asymmetrical combative engagement
wherein the other person is way bigger
than you okay and so you always see
people and they're always doing sport
applications where they're out musling a
person that they're able to out muscle
you never ever see them doing it on uh a
a another cop training partner who's got
100 pound on them or you never see the
135 female officer now trying to do it
on a guy that's 200 lb okay because it's
it doesn't
work all right so we going into what
does this non-contest contestation look
like in iido such that I would call it a
spiral
rotation uh or a spiral rotating cross
okay we know first from o sensei's
writings that he referred to juji and
juji is uh this is this is how you write
the character for the number 10 in Kani
in Japanese and this J is number 10 and
G means character so the 10 character is
what juji means we in chibba Lage we
have juji G nag where the person's UK's
arm is across my arm perpendicular to it
and hence it makes a cross and hence
juji Net 10 characters from okay and we
know ensei referred to juji um and we
know from Silk Road culture that the
internal Arts refer to this pattern and
this is actually why on the Silk Road
you see the
cross um everywhere across whether it's
OB obviously uh on the western end you
you understand Christianity has the
cross um knowing for a fact that uh C
crosses was not actually how Romans
crucified people okay um and then even
on the uh East End you see variations on
the cross if not outright the cross
okay um other things that you might see
is like this symbol uh the swastika
symbols you have the cross in there and
what this represents is uh a
diagrammatic form of yinong or dichotomy
or
dualistic um thinking that goes with the
Triune cosmology of silk road so you
have two things they're not really two
things there's a Oneness behind them all
and and it's represented with this kind
of Crossing okay even for
example um
in Judaism now we have this star of
David that people identify with Judaism
but this too is a yinyang symbol uh not
and you would see it outside of judaic
traditions along that Silk Road
okay all right in iido if we understand
this we'll just use the East End
understanding of this we have yin and
yang okay we have two forces at their
more most pure states of opposition
across okay
um UK's energy we'll stick with UK as
opposed to an enemy let's say UK's
energy is
coming
horizontally left to right right
okay um an oppositional
energy is going to go in the opposite
direction right to left okay this would
be contestation this is a no no you
never do this in
iido this however is how most modern
iido functions people will push on UK's
energy and here we have to understand
energy with either mass inertia or
momentum okay and we push on UK we
overcome the resistance of that energy
and now force it the other way this is
how most people understand iido today
but this is incorrect this is actually
contestation it is not non-c
contestation okay so we want to note
here we should not be contending we
should be non-c contesting and
contention is when we are applying this
uh equal and opposite direction in the
effort to
overpower the force that's coming right
at us okay what we want to do instead in
iido let's keep this horizontal
energy is apply a uh Force to it at 90°
okay so instead of applying a 100 80°
counter Force to it we would apply
another Force coming in at this angle
okay and you can imagine just very
simply like a lever you're at the distal
end of the lever and this marker is
going this way and I'm going to push it
this way
okay this is a very very simple thing
that I'm doing so I I make this 90° here
what happens though as I start to turn
this Force well you have to keep the 90°
so as you're doing this with this Force
this force is now going like this you
have to keep that 90° going to that
Force as it's going around and so these
two lines which if you overextended it
do you
see start to rotate this way okay and
that's why it is the cross and we're
rotating it all right why do I call it
spiral spiraling
because we have to have the third
dimension uh which is not drawable here
on this whiteboard and as you start to
start this this cross spiral or rotating
when you allow for the Third Dimension
the whole cross now starts to spiral
through space and hence it is a spiral
rotation
that we're constantly seeking as we seek
a 90° angle constantly to uh UK Mass
imersa momentum okay we never
push uh in opposition to it that's what
we're doing so again this is a cultural
abstraction of those two cosmological
forces okay and then uh we have here
okay let's apply what we we know about
these two cosmological forces and so
that we produce non-c contestation and
what that is is that we're going to do
this constant we're going to do a 90°
angle to whatever Force Vector we're
dealing with that Force Vector in this
case is representative of ukas mass
inertia momentum okay uh the opposite
again the contention angle would be that
we're here and we're making this 180
okay all
right as we apply this in practice
however uh this is a constant thing it
can't be this simple
abstract you know two lines it's a
constant 90° to the mass inertia and
momentum of UK and so you have this
rotation that is happening and then
because there's a third dimension this
is actually going either down or it's
going up up as it's traversing also
across the mat and so you have to kind
of visualize this as a spiral a
spiraling pattern okay that's what we
just discussed the other thing we want
to understand is because within this
pattern there is a circularity to it
okay and an important thing to note is
that a circle has two side two sides to
it in a way um I
and what we want to draw out of this is
anything that is going forward so in
this case from left to right can be made
to go back right to left without it
reversing okay so we use this circle to
take energy that's coming left to right
let's say in this case and we will round
this keeping the
body going in the forward motion but now
headed in the opposite direction okay
what would be different from the from
that is this contention model where I
now try to overpower it do you see and
now this force over overpowered is also
heading in that direction that's we
don't do that in iida okay we can
achieve the 180 Dee other direction
without having to stop it reverse it or
overpower it by a allowing it to
continue to go forward on a circle and
of course the same thing can be done in
terms of the verticality by bringing
something down and if you continue It
Forward you can bring it up or vice
versa you can bring it up and eventually
if you keep the circle going they'll
eventually be going down okay we want to
understand that as well and likewise
because of this depending on uh when
where I am in the
circle energy from my perspective can
either be uh outward
projecting or inward projecting okay
there can either be centrical energy or
centrifical energy and we use that
constantly okay if I want to pin someone
for example I position myself in a when
wear where all of this stuff this spiral
rotating and the nature of circles will
generate an inward uh uh energy that I
use to pin that person when I want to
throw them I position myself in a where
when in the circle to uh use the
centrifugal energy to project them away
from me
okay okay so a as I I got to give you
one more thing as we generate both of
these possibil ities of the circular
pattern which is that I can keep things
going forward but actually send them
back on the and on its 180° very very
very important and the same thing with
going up and down okay and as I can be
in The Circle at a certain when where
and I generate centrifugal energy or
centripetal energy also very important
okay you have to remember that this 90
is a
constant um 90° application okay and
that means that in particular when iido
uses cental energy for pinning and
centrifugal energy for
throwing and I have to generate these
forces within a constant application of
90° the only way you can do that is that
from your single contact point
you can generate this constant 90°
variation that means internal
skills so if I want to
touch your shoulder or your Center or
your other foot you see from one point
it's because I can keep from that single
point energy being applied to you at
different vectors and you cannot do that
from a physical external touch you have
to keep moving it's not possible okay
likewise when I want to
throw I have to throw at a constant
adapting 90° Vector to whatever you're
doing otherwise I'm just pushing you
okay and that would be your C and it
would be the same thing from wherever
I'm touching I keep modulating for the
90° from wherever I'm touching okay
which is why
within II and CQ is not only a kind of
internal non-c contestation in the sense
that yin and yangong ultimately get
reconciled um but there is the seed of
the physical non-c contestation you
can't really do this with you having to
regrab um which most people don't or
reposition most people don't what they
end up doing is eventually they hit the
180 as they failed to keep modulating
for the updating 90° and they now hit
the 180 and they just overpower the 180
and that's why um you UK look so
different on how you're thrown and how
you fall versus other UK who can do um
all their crazy front Brak Falls right
in the same vertical plane for example
they're not hit with the x pattern or in
some some cases uh the back breakfall
they can just sit their butt down or
even do a back somersault or back
backwards roll which is totally
impossible for how we Throw because this
is constantly being modulated and your
body itself is spiral rotating okay
which is what makes it very very hard to
become skilled in our ukemi style
because it is balls scary as
okay right and most of us can't uh
reconcile that amount of fear and so
what do we have to do we have to go back
to this model which allows you to just
go backwards or go forward okay which is
not really the art okay all
right okay um so we'll just work from
here oh I me sorry IH okay so we'll just
work from IH because I that's what you
were working from okay I'm not going to
go into this stuff I just want to go
into this non-c contestation so I I
don't I'm not going to go into the
um um tabaki okay I'm not going to go
in um but you guys see for yourself that
I'm going to I'm going to move
him as opposed to him staying there and
then me going around
so I moved him you see the difference
Okay because I'm going to use circles
okay I don't I just take figure that out
you can figure that out it looks totally
different does it not looks totally
different totally different okay right
right okay
um but I want to look
at the energy that I start to use to
take him down okay so however I got
there you could
see that his energy is either was either
going to go forward in my version or it
staying still okay face me
again even staying
still has mass and inertia
okay so that is a force and all I'm
doing here is Supply what its
force is going up down do you guys
understand that okay and all I am trying
to do is shove it down that's all I'm
trying to do if I could I smash him down
like that you see but I
can't so I smashing it
down just enough where I can't do it
anymore and that's what causes him to
turn Okay And now when you add my
movement to that
stay there I don't want you to move when
you add my movement to that that's what
makes this pulling do you
see now if I brought him forward then I
be pull on the backward then then the
the contention is obvious
okay but there's another way to do this
and that is I position myself within the
Circle and I have his
Mass going up and down and now going
forward okay because I would have the
two uh Force vectors in my version of
the technique
okay and I'm going to position myself in
a place that when he goes I I'll do it
here physically when he goes forward say
that when he goes
forward go go forward that it holds him
here
then when he is staying still at the
same time the energy that has him
staying still right um I am going to
allow it to turn it's very hard to do
from here because of the slack that you
have there energy is spilling out all
over the place okay but once I come to
to the
adhesion okay and I want you to feel
that okay and he goes forward then I can
keep cutting these little increments
those n constant 90° angle to what he's
doing okay so here again if he tries to
go forward I keep taking it that way he
tries to go forward I take it 90° he
tries to go forward and I take it 90°
and it's easy
okay so that's that's why I keep him
moving and it's easy
peasy
whoa and you cannot do that externally I
could do it here but now I start losing
it you see I I got it from here to here
here but now when he goes forward we're
on the 180 do you see okay and so that's
where I just show
that were you able to get that does that
make sense okay so instead I do start
him rotating but I just keep that 90
going which means I have to constantly
turn
okay now back to that uh centripetal
energy here okay so I need him to keep
going forward if I stop this and I'm
just using the 90 90 you can do that
okay but I'm going to lose
him so I need him to keep going forward
and get that balance
going is what I
want then you just stay with
it so on the one example I'm
demonstrating the the the the inertia
that I'm using
there sorry
not but that cental energy and now all I
here stay with
it then I'm
here room stay with it stay with
it
okay it's different
from I'm here and I pull him me
different I stay with what was happening
in the correct way and this other thing
I'm making it happen by just over power
in
okay so just as I have to move
myself such that I can continue the
90° to
your
energy I have to also be in this right
place time in order to capitalize upon
the Cent the cental energy of my I
adhesion okay try to again couple key
differences here in order to generate
everything we're talking about is what I
actually need them to keep going forward
I I can't have them stay
still because even if I apply
90 on the same adhesion Point
eventually I'm going to start right
about here I'm now pulling this thing
back to me
okay which is OB when you watch the ghee
okay so as I watch the ghee true that is
a 90 but now if I keep going 90 he's
going to go away from me you see and at
a certain point you'll watch his ghe you
see how the ghe comes back cuz I'm
pulling on him
okay so key key difference is the Uka
does have to keep going forward
okay another key difference here is that
I don't stop moving uh and the UK
doesn't stop moving we all keep
moving so when the UK stops moving I
don't move the UK and I come around you
see he didn't move and now I move now he
moves and in the other one we all keep
moving at the same time that's another
key difference to telling you am I doing
this or am I not doing this that is
observable from a third party okay at
this point what is observable to him is
he can feel the
adhesion gaining this centripetal energy
because of the May being in the right
place time within the circle that I'm
generating he he feels that that kind of
thing on him imagine if you had good we
had a better camera and they focused on
that you would see it on his face but
he's able to feel it
okay um
something
else is my hand again I remember I said
that
uh it's more that I stay up with it
versus I put him underneath me I stay up
with it which follows my rule that I'm
just aiming a fallen body I'm not
throwing him down okay so a as we're
moving and I get it I you won't see
this
stuff you won't see that and he doesn't
feel that either right like if he comes
uh in other words do you feel that
difference okay that difference okay
this is what you feel right cuz at this
point he would fall out of dead hean
because I'm not going to do this okay
but because of the C he he can't you
can't lift straight up go ahead you
can't lift straight up where whereas
strangely as I go like this and I'm just
here you can push up you see get it so
you look for that like your ukas should
not feel smashed at the bottom they
should feel like I can get up
okay so as you're watching that you can
see like here at the bottom I'm just
maintaining light contact my I'm not
here he's not under me
do you see he's here
okay so we'll go
again just it's light at that point okay
um this is what allows me to do
something that after I get going a while
I I end up doing it I'm not even sure I
can do it consciously but I end up
turning around again okay
because I'm not pinning him down at that
point so we go
around and I'm over
here not over here see this
difference
so see where I
am I'm going to be over
here instead
no I'll keep 10 coning up up
up will'll be here okay either
way if I don't ten
conon this hand is
light if I do t con again this hand is
light but light does not mean he can
pick it up he count you can try count
this is same Cy extension okay and now
the beauty of this
technique is I just applied the rotating
cross
horizontally and now I'm going to apply
it vertically okay which fits with the
Triune cosmology you have to do both
okay so we going around one way boom and
now I take that
verticality okay so when he tries to
come up I don't try to shove him down I
don't try to grab him and pull him and
if he is choreographed to go forward I'm
not worried about him coming
up okay because there was no pressure
let's go back to where you were because
there was no pressure he'll he should
feel the yin space which means he should
try to come
up okay and that means I have a force
going this way well that means I apply
that ever modulating 90° he comes up and
I just keep bringing it
forward it looks like he's
crawling he is because if he doesn't put
his hands forward he would fall again
okay
um let's just get there okay leave your
hands where they are and come up
so he puts his hands there as he tries
to come up or it he puts his hands there
okay this down okay but how I'm moving
him is the adhesion will come back into
place okay so for yes yes as he tries to
come up you can do that okay that's
still the 90° but eventually as he goes
up and he moves in I'm now in the a
place where I got to now pull him okay
or shove him down cuz he's going to
stand up all the way okay but with the
adhesion as he goes up he he being moved
and I'll show you what I mean by
that okay um don't don't come forward
don't come forward you got it and I'm
just using that adhesion to move him
forward okay and it's just as he comes
up I'm also applying that 90° modulation
but it's done with a adhesion so that
when he comes up and I move him
around I can keep the ever modulating 90
Dees Fuller until the circle now
reverses itself he's going forward but
he's actually going the other way okay
okay so you're doing it
twice boom here
boom okay let's try it and you have that
same need to be in the right place time
the right wind wear in order to generate
this cental energy on the vertical
and the way that you do this is the
energy tells you where to move you don't
move the UK to where you want to go so
first let me show you uh what happens
when we move the UK to where we want to
go okay so I'm coming around here and
then here and here okay and in that
eventually you're going to not be 90° to
their mass inertia momentum and you're
just pulling in this case or pushing
eventually and now you're contesting
what's going on okay um sometimes what
happens on my Desy hair as you're
getting all this going is you just you
lose the connection here go ahead and uh
you're like over here well you shouldn't
have stepped here this energy told you
to step here you see okay so you have to
put yourself where the energy can keep
its constant
90° modulation okay
right I can't let you go and I'm over
here and I'm pulling you into this thing
I keep the energy that I feel keep
that so that I'm always there for the
throw okay again some differences that
you'll
see is we'll get to this part
is the the hand on the neck is the
dominant throwing hand
until you reach the yinyang transition
which happens at 12:00 okay instead what
you'll see is he comes up and this hand
is the dominant hand and you start grows
like that okay because this hand has the
adhesion point when he goes
forward and he comes up here this hand's
doing all of that it's not till at this
point the energy that I was bringing
down and around I would now be pulling
at 90° to at at 180 to his wanting to
stay up do you see so that is when this
hat now takes over and when it takes
over
it doesn't go down it goes here he
doesn't want to go down to this energy
goes this
way keeps that 90° going okay so
you'll see what that looks like here it
is and then up this way
[Music]
okay it doesn't have anything to do with
how many times you ten con or if you ten
con at all you're just doing this
constant degree 90°
modulation e